justement quel est plus beau cadeau
qu'on vous ait fait bénigne le plus beau
cadeau qu'on m'ait fait j'avais j'avais
très envie j'ai attendu d'avoir mes 45
ans pour avoir un babyliss non non je
voulais une très très très belle montre
parce que j'adore les montres j'en
rêvais depuis que j'avais 10 vous avez
une flic floc et j'ai eu cette très
belle montre que j'ai pas là au poignet
mais que non et c'est ma tâche amap mon
papa ma maman et mon amoureux soit
offert sont mis à trois c'est à dire la
banque trop dieu bénisse et j'ai avisé
pour des 45 mètres cube et du coup le
fait d'attendre ses 18 ans un objet bien
précis quand on l'obtient battu d'un
coup c'est comme une meuf sa lutte à toi
aussi tu kiffes c'est pas faux non mais
c'est vrai plaisir et dans voici les
menus confirme ce quoi mais j'aurais
aimé vous faut plutôt pour moi mon fils
a trop hâte à mme labasse tirez-vous ça
fait quand même si c'est vrai ou c'est
le plus beau cadeau que vous ayez une
moto quand j'étais jeune quand j'avais
16 ans non avait acheté une moto gp
attendais pas du tout c'est une moto de
cross ne voulais pas qu'il était médecin
et oui ils avaient trop peur des motos
ils paient pas que j'aille sur la route
où j'avais un pont fumer je vais jouer
moto de cross vous pouvez pas aller sur
la route donc pendant trois jours j'ai
labouré le jardin familial et vous le
quatrième jour bages et frimer devant
les copines dont le bistrot de d'epinal
domaine de l'histoire
le bistrot d'epinal le second collégien
et qu'est ce que vous aimeriez avoir
comme cadeau cette année une autre
tinette électrique encore fera partie
des cadeaux tout à l'heure et si la
crois qu'il est parti
delphine c'est quoi votre plus beau
cadeau qu'on vous avait été miss ont
séparé que sa pire année
ah bon ouais c'est beaucoup confié à moi
vous savez
[Rires]
je vais pas dire mon plus beau cadeau
parce que je suis pas du tout
matérialiste chez jamais qu'est ce que
j'aurais pu jouer je vais de mon plus
beau noël c'était il ya trois ans on est
tout fraîchement ensemble accroché je
crois que c'est quand à lui acheter sa
première manche en plastique
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu me donnes tu es trop tôt schmidt
et quand il a aidé quand elle a présenté
ses bars en effet on y sert des jours ça
va mon plus beau noël donc en fait on
l'appelle à sa robe mais c'est
aujourd'hui oui je termine donc on a
passé le noël que a2a avait les boules
à moins qu'à 20h - ça qu'on a dit on
voulait pas faire à manger si ça en
italie dans un supermarché on a juste à
c d e du pain en fait on courait dans
les rayons on faisait comme ça et au
final à tour au jeu l'a fait sur le
canapé on a fait des jeux nous y est
comme ca annuel
est ce que les hugo noyait tous nous y
est nous y est on y est les yaka faut
vous dire il n'y avait pas tous les gros
trucs mais c'était génial d'un gain
serré c'était sur un camion dit régis
bulot on dirait une pub pour naquirent
tas
[Musique]
rocher chez les ja
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est pas le cadeau qui compte
c'est avec qui on le passe et surtout là
sincèrement j'en ai parlé comme un
cerneau de noix alors et c'est quoi le
cadeau que vous aimeriez voir cette
année elle a déjà l'amour normal oui oui
oui non tout simplement là la santé de
mes proches et lorraine pour pouvoir
rester à vos cabas je vous dis je vous
dis alors ces erreurs là quand on a la
santé la santé en a 7 min le jour de
l'an c'est surtout la santé je peux te
dire daniel alors daniel c'est quoi
c'était quoi te le plus beau cadeau de
noël que tu ai eu dix mois peut-être une
traction avant
le truc le plus aimé je crois c'est une
poupée qui parle qui m'avait offert vous
savez il y avait des c était vrai la
poupée bernès ta gueule
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tout et quand il était jeune et faire
une poupée permet d'améliorer la poupée
qui fait peur à tous les enfants
[Rires]
le quinze jours je peux un jour qu'on va
faire mais ça ne s'est pas fait que des
freins alors vous c'était presque savent
enfin c'était une jolie poupée blonde
accord il y avait des petits disques et
puis on mettait pilule d'accord on n'a
pas besoin des grands jours c'est quoi
et si non alors voile et les noël c'est
toujours les mêmes depuis très très
longtemps nous aussi on est à 2 nous
savons à martic mais c'est avec ma mère
toujours pareil une demi langouste
chacune ah ouais moi pas et on regarde
le concert d'andré rieu est vite ses
marques et chaque heure vous ouvrez les
veines
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
langoustes et concernant brillait au
cern en effet rien toujours la même
famille de ma mère c'est ça mon méchant
et on devrait juste 15 à une nation je
le rajoute dans les mauvais cadeau je
vous le dis je le rajoute un énorme
cadeau
[Applaudissements]
j'aurai une boîte sur une boîte oui
alors c'est pour le service après vente
merci merci
vous le savez je suis un mélomane averti
un passionné de musique vous comprenez
ce que vous dites là d'accord et mon
plus beau cadeau je les ai reçus à 7 ans
c'était un synthétiseur d'accord et des
heures supprimées premier cours de
musique j'ai fait vingt ans de piano
ouais et puis me voilà un peu rock stars
are your say brooks tard baroque on
regroupe starch dans ma chambre pas
suffi et c'est quoi le cadeau que vous
aimeriez avoir
vous savez mon cadeau ouais plus
important des cadeaux c'est moi l'un des
chantres à chercher mais c'est vous et
en plus de ça mon cadeau qui arrivent et
ils vont perdre dans les choix de
poursuivre mon rêve et je réalise chaque
jour mon rêve d'être ici mais en de
partager
[Musique]
et celles qui
c'est qu'il sait que je laime maxime je
lâcherai jamais j'te j tony est à tour
bull c'est la période
moi même alors je regarde si on est
petit on n'a pas le droit d'être un peu
bienveillant et un peu sympa avec une
personne qu'on aime et ben écoutez
franchement on a bien commencé a
commencé mais ma monna reste le coup
maintenant mais ma monna on a du mal à
le découper
oui alors oui on peut m'appeler vos
cadeaux oui un déménagement
comment faire ouais on a ainsi abaissé
de meuf qui vous débarrassez battu voilà
les déménageurs tu veux monter cliquez
là que tu dégages connard alors là on
avait déménagé mon appartement pour en
faire un nid d'amour avec la personne et
de cadeaux qui vous donne le prénom
sandrine à l'époque sandrine ah ouais on
en a déjà entendu parler sipa c'est que
vous avez découvert dans les essais de
l'oulle d'escale terminé way oui vous
avez entendu des bruits d'animaux et
elle avec un mec voilà une histoire qui
a bien terminé que je connaissais pas
cette histoire je vous le dis il a est
en fait il a entendu des bruits
d'animaux mais en fait c'était sandrine
avec nîmes à dire le cadeau de noël sur
wii
un mariage non ouais ouais c'est le cas
d'auxerre mais ça fait trois ans que
j'ai donné la bague la mariage et à
écouter ci fans souhaitant le choix
s'est fait pour nous oui eh ben moi mon
cadeau de mon fils oh oui
[Applaudissements]
il est né à noël françois noël mais non
ehpad à noël
c'était beau noël daucé
c'est très mignon et sinon quand j'étais
petit un téléphérique que je m'étais
entre deux chefs j'avais demandé un
cadeau ou pas et si ça vous aimeriez
avoir comme cadeau monde isa alors mais
vraiment vraiment vraiment que tous mes
proches sont en bonne santé que pour une
fois cette année personne soit malade à
noël djè un beau cadeau christine quitte
alors mois déjà alors on promis c'est
vrai que j'ai eu un jour à noël qu'est
ce que vous avez
je pense que oui on l'a fait beau cadeau
que j'ai eu deux servis en 24 décembre
au soir c'était ma demande en mariage
non du nom de son ancien comme un loup
elle encore dans la tête
ah mais on est toujours amis non ouais
c'est marais longtemps c'est votre
meilleure amie
non tout près de toi toujours courtois
hélas si c'était voilà c'était une très
très très gauche a demandé en vain le 24
décembre au soir avec une très très
jolie bague
non mais vous avez des électrodes
alors non je vais pas les 23 ans sa date
en fait alors et et puis voilà donc
c'était un très très très très beau et
l'occasion de la voir dans ce que mme en
quoi il a largué le premier jour c'est
une offre très bon départ de design
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
prévention peut dire à roscoff
d'alléchantes un plat
merci rien ne compte plus moi que la
famille et le nord 4 je prends l'avion
je vais en guadeloupe géant famille a
way sera une cinquantaine pour que
c'était vrai voilà j'étais honneur pour
moi c'est pas venu d'ailleurs j'étais
venu au lycée vrai et m'a présenté sa
famille avant de me payer plein cousin
cousine la totale et voilà donc c'est ça
c'est julien de plus que m
on est comme ça et de on est copains
mais c'est un truc de ouf alors vous
bonsoir s'accroît la parfumerie cela oui
et moi mon plus beau cadeau c'est cette
semaine avec vous les engagements
entendent à présent
puis c'est long et c'est bon merci s'ils
ont mal aux cadeaux et cadeaux vous
aimeriez avoir continué continue et
voilà de quoi bien raymond boucherit moi
mon plus beau cadeau c'était un vélo de
cross motobécane série limitée hollywood
chewing gum a été magnifique avec les
gens vers un métier que je suis là il
doit être très beau navet les super il
est super et cet [ __ ] de chauffeur de
bus le 235 à regarde juste à dilma il
m'a serré il a roulé sur le vélo juste
le temps de sauter du vélo je regardais
quinze jours mais c'est mon plus beau
cadeau de noël le cadeau vous aimeriez
voir et bien le cadeau un peu comme les
camarades je les ai eus parce que vous
m'avez offert une récré yade pendant
deux mois c'est extraordinaire et du
coup bas que ce que mes proches sont en
bonne santé et du coup on va mettre un
peu plus de jouer sous le sapin c'était
pas prévu et ben finalement grâce à vous
c'est
voici l'allumé 12 ans vous avez des
postes d'infirmiers et mon père m'avait
emmené au concert d'hélène ségara
l'olympia ouais c'est pas vrai show elle
avait chanté à trop de gens qui t'aiment
bien sûr mais tu ne vois j'ai adoré je
ne sortirai pas la zone cet amour avec
toi ya trop de gens qui te tutoie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand ferme les yeux on y ait un sac à
main quel cadeau rêvé aux demandes par
an il traînait life bomba très bien et
bien vous avez raison vous avez un père
noël derrière